in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions chin is
with us hi Jen how are you hi Dave I'm
wonderful how are you better than I
deserve welcome where are you from where
do you live I am from Oregon Wisconsin
it's about 20 minutes south of Madison
okay very cool well who's the young man
wait this is my youngest son Brayden
he's seven very cool and you're here all
the way from Wisconsin to Tennessee to
do your debt-free screen I love it how
much have you paid off
I paid off about eleven thousand eight
hundred dollars in 12 months good for
you also cash flowed about two thousand
nine hundred and fifty dollars for car
repairs we went to Florida over
Christmas mm-hmm to see family my 15
year old took a missions trip to Ecuador
so I had to pay for her passport and
shots and then we adopted a puppy right
before I got debt-free so that was
another dollar so so what's your
household income between 42 and 43
thousand dollars okay what do you do I
do customer service or a marketing
company good so what kind of debt was
this $12,000 well some of it was my
cellphone a couple hundred dollars I had
finance the cellphone the majority of it
was a home improvement credit card
mm-hmm
pre Dave Ramsey I about two years ago in
June of 2015 I bought a condo mm-hmm and
then I kind of got the home improvement
bug and decided I wanted to start
replacing the windows so I was only
gonna have them come over for an
estimate but you know they can be a
little pushy so I ended up getting the
windows in January of 2016 and then I
had heard about you years ago a friend
that I worked with had introduced me to
the plan but I thought I was doing okay
you know being a single mom I didn't
have a lot of credit card or anything
like that but I did have some and then
when I realized how much the windows
were and that my income was actually
gonna be going down in June of this year
because my oldest turned 18 so I wasn't
gonna get child support anymore I was
like I need to get rid of this before he
leaves the house whoa so
I remembered the CDs that my friend had
let me borrow and I bought the Total
Money Makeover I started watching the
show on YouTube pretty much every single
day got really involved with the chat
and then got on the program and I wanted
to get it done by June of this year I
finished in March of 2017
so the youtubers are on there cheering
right now
I love them but one of their community
is is here in person to do the debt free
scream yeah I love the the YouTube
crazies that's what we that's what we
call ourselves the people that have been
and kind of watching it from the start
they were a huge support for me and
motivated me and kept me on track and
just you know really helped me to stay
committed to the plan because it was
hard sometimes in you're a single mom
I've got three boys oh yeah yeah well
you got to have somebody in your corner
cheering you on and also it's also you
know kind of a place to confess if you
goof up and that kind of stuff you know
the community community is powerful on
this Isle of those guys they're amazing
well congratulations so you know the
dumb mistake put the pressure on yep and
then the pressure says hey we gotta get
the CDs back out get the copy the Total
Money Makeover book and game on and then
jump in with a community on YouTube but
here we go yep and I downloaded every
dollar and have been using that you know
since April of last year and I just yeah
I just kind of went for it I was like I
need to get this done and I was yeah
happy that I got it done three months
before my actual goal getting it done so
great very cool very cool good for you
so what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is budget mm-hmm
obviously and having accountability and
not only accountability but
encouragement I mean it can be really
difficult
you know I'm single I do it by my I did
it all by myself not can be it is it is
difficult especially I think when you're
single and you've got kids that want
things and you know you have to have
people that are willing to remind you
when you might get sidetracked one lady
said when you're the only grown-up in
the house
you have to be the only grown-up in the
house which is not always when you've
got teenage boys persuasive to me they
definitely are so you know having the
people there that you know I could go to
and knowing that I could watch the show
every single day and watch other people
do their debt-free scream and you know
know that other people that maybe were
even making more money or had two people
in the house versatile struggling so you
don't feel like you're all alone yeah
impressive you're raising all these kids
and you do 12,000 bucks in 12 months I'm
making 42 those are great numbers I mean
you but you've been game home kiddo I
have I you know as a single mom I
enjoyed you know stewing little stuff
for myself I you know had a t-shirt club
I belong to and that was thirty dollars
a month and you wouldn't think it's a
lot for $30 a month is $30 a month so I
left that out I really like going to
live concerts and I don't mind
travelling for them so I was going to a
couple every single year I got those out
we've been to one concert in a year and
it was $10 for tickets mhm and it was
like an hour way so we haven't done you
know really any kind of extracurricular
or anything mm-hmm you know what Miller
you just get it done
absolutely that's why were here what was
your biggest thing you learned about you
while you're doing this um that I'm
capable of doing anything I set my mind
to
mm yeah that's what I was thinking and
that being debt-free and having the
freedom to be able to make changes in my
life you know like maybe career-wise if
I need be you know I can do that now
because I don't have I'm not saddled
with that and done you know there's
hanging over your head right they do a
really good job when you're doing stuff
like that of convincing you like oh you
only have to pay this amount of money
for five years and it's like I don't
want to be strapped with us in five
years and then have to make that payment
for five years will you ever go back in
debt no no no I want to do the mortgage
I think it's probably gonna take me a
little bit longer than seven years since
I'm doing it by myself but I mean I'm
just I'm focused yeah you'll get there
I'm focused no doubt you're gonna get
there you're a rock star
very well yeah very proud of you thank
you we'll get a copy of Chris Hogan's
retire inspired book for you thank you
to be the next chapter in your story as
you become now that you're debt-free now
you become a millionaire I hope you will
thank you you will I don't know exactly
how much time it's going to take you but
you're gonna get there
and you'll be amazed that it actually is
going to happen I've seen some pretty
incredible numbers come out of people
who actually pay attention and you you
are one of them so well done very well
done and your son's name again Braden
Braden and Jen from Madison Wisconsin
$12,000 paid off in twelve months making
forty two thousand a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one we're dead
yeah that's how we do it good job get
out very well done and I love it hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]